we're gonna get to the good see wits now
we're getting to the light of the day
star cancer battle it's going to be a
lot of hatchet
what are you thinking about the prospect
of marrying Cersei [ __ ] no way I
think it's I think it's a real shame for
Loras like to be in that position
especially after red knee well you may
looking forward to and the word working
at dependence and season for her they
are they want to portray it but it
doesn't say it's we have time involved
in working well there's a lot of fun
it's a wholly different motion for Hodor
if it's not the calm gentle soul is
something completely different
what would you like to see happen with
the Dragons in future I'm kind of
wondering how big they're gonna get are
they going to be indefinitely as
pitiable as they currently are you know
because as they get bigger one presumes
they will get more independence my
favorite character is probably ire so I
just I'm really looking forward to
seeing how her character develops in the
next series and if it's the same as the
book I don't see how Maisie gets on with
the Hound I imagine it Arya will end up
in Braavos at some point and we'll use
the coin I've always seen Arya is kind
of being on her own in the end a lot of
the characters need their army more
you know Jeffrey isn't ring anything
without CFC as I seen in that series
whatever she after pure malice comes and
mocks me it was great fun to do because
that naughty girl that naughty actress
this is so gorgeous Lina her eyes were
so full of mockery and amusement at her
own success and when she walked away
from the city of Tyre and says to her
you're in a good mood today simple
pleasures and that is just to take a
piss out of myself like Lawrence being
there is no I don't think both of them
both of them are not keen on the
prospect both in hate the idea and I
think that mutual hate of the plan might
actually bring them together in it in a
very strange way you know also be
interesting to see now that Jamie's lost
his hand
Lawrence has actually got the upper hand
you know he you know he has the power so
I think there's there's some
possibilities some very interesting
dynamics between the two characters I
want to see more of Jaime and Brienne I
want to see more of that they're
brilliant
Jamie Lannister is really
and the relationship he has with him
written country mountain area yeah I
really hope their relationship gets
stronger see the way he rode that boat
at the end of the series up I think it
bodes well for him it would just be good
to see if you can make it to dry land
what Gendry does next because you know
we haven't seen him on his own what
about the Brotherhood without banners
what do you think they'll get up to next
well I think they're doing a good job
protecting the weak and them as
fortunate but if there is a war coming
and it looks like there is you know I
think those boys should be should be at
the forefront the best thing to happen I
think someone take down Joffrey I don't
matter how but as long as he's down
that's good for me poison maybe there's
a lot of people around him who could
poison him very easily and that would be
a slow lingering death so I'd like that
I think I'd like to think that they will
you know bring bring him back I think
it'd be totally over his terrible wound
that you got a Blackwater was all by
then and their awful pain it was
inflicted I know he's heartbroken and
he's probably shoulder broken as well
from that wound so I think there's a lot
of hip there's a lot thinking to kind of
deal with but that's that's where
they've maybe a religion will pop into
play you wait till you see how Charlie
dance dies that is really funny somebody
in the street who've been reading all
the books you know say check okay death
scene I said Oh have I what is the
manner of my death and he told me it's
quite spectacular if Mary's story lie
which happens in the
where she goes into this man cave with
like children of the forest and like
it's incredible and if that makes its
way into the series and absolutely love
it that sounds wicked if you could bring
someone back to life who would it be to
bring back Michelle wonderful she does
such an amazing performance I'd love to
see more of her in the show Catelyn
probably when I can we've lost our
matriarch I think I bring Kaitlyn back
to life a fantastically rounded woman
ultimately you go but who's gonna who's
gonna kick the Lannisters who's good at
what what's now what's gonna happen but
of course that's the great thing you
don't know hey you know we are fortunate
enough to have dragons our problem is
also that we happen to have dragons
final question for you Christian hodor
hodor hodor hodor hodor hodor and on
that bombshell of what we can expect
from a season four thank you very much
Christian Oh Rob